[Music]
all right welcome back so we're looking
at the eigenfaces example where we take
a library of people's faces reshaped
into column vectors and when we compute
the SVD of this matrix we get these
orthonormal eigen faces which are the
columns of U and these provide an
orthonormal basis to represent human
faces in okay now what's really neat
about this is that you can use this for
image classification so if you have an
image X instead of doing classification
in a high dimensional maybe megapixel
image space what you can do is you can
take that that image X and you can
project it into the first R dimensional
eigen face coordinates the first four
columns of U transposed and what you get
out is this little A or alpha vector
which is kind of a fingerprint for that
person's face in this basis and in this
low dimensional representation what
we're going to show is that you can have
people cluster and you can use that
clustering for building a classification
algorithm so if I have a new picture I
can tell if it's person a or person B
based on where it lands in this R
dimensional subspace so here what we're
gonna do is we're gonna just randomly
pick person two and person seven from my
library we're gonna pull only their
faces and we're gonna project them into
the first into the fifth and sixth
principal component or column of U so
what I'm going to do is I'm going to
pick the fifth and the sixth column of U
and I'm gonna basically take the inner
product and all of my images with those
two columns the fifth and the sixth
column and I'm gonna get a
two-dimensional vector alpha and when I
plot my data I'm essentially plotting it
in principle component five versus
principal component six okay and when I
do that what we see is that person to
and person seven really nicely cluster
in this principal component space okay
so almost all of the white diamonds for
person two are up here and almost all of
the blue triangles for persons sub
are down here and what that means is
that you can build a pretty efficient
and accurate classifier so if I have a
new picture of person 2 I'll be able to
tell because chances are if I take that
new picture and take its inner product
with these principal components it will
drop near all of the other white
diamonds and if I take a picture of
person 7 it'll probably end up near the
blue triangles and you can use this for
a classification so this is at least
kind of a rudimentary sketch of how
Facebook might tell different people
apart in images using low dimensional
features okay and just to show you you
can actually plot person person two so I
took the first person image and I
plotted that if you want to see what the
second person looks like they look like
that so those are the two people that
were we're telling apart and they very
very nicely separate and cluster in this
space okay so this is pretty cool you
can use these principal components or
the SVD modes your eigenfaces to do
classification also and I'll point out
it's no coincidence that I chose
principal component five and six and not
principal component one and two so the
first two principal components at least
with faces generally encode all of the
information that is the same among all
people so all of us basically have an
oval and eyes and a nose and a mouth and
the first three principal components
that capture the most variance in this
data are actually the information that
most of us have in common
okay the information that is different
from person to person you know different
geometry of the eyebrows and the nose
and the spacing of the the different
features that's encoded in the
lower-energy singular values four or
five six and so on so if I plotted this
for and the first instead of PCA modes
five and six let's say I do I don't know
one and two look how well the separation
is here there's almost no separation of
the the two people in this this these
two principal components one and two the
those are the features that generally
are the same or in this Yale faces
database maybe its shadow differences or
things like that okay so if I go back to
five and six we recover our really nice
separation nice clean separation and the
cool thing about this is you can
download this you can play around with
this you can you can play with your own
pick your own PCA modes see if you can
get a better separation or interpret
what these different modes are doing
okay thank you